I want to go back to uh we were just
talking about uh I was just talking with
Russell about uh NoHo and how it is such
an iconic record on the west coast but
it also is a record that doesn't sound
like it was mixed or mastered it sounds
like you've got the studio bounce and
just rolled with that there that's
exactly what I did yeah I recorded it so
okay so you just balance it out you're
like I did everything I did the beat I
recorded it and I did the I didn't know
how to mix or nothing like that I didn't
know what plugins was I didn't know what
none of that was I just knew how to
press record and adjust the volumes of
each track you feel me and and that was
that do you remember like um
that specific record obviously is like a
record that changed your life but do you
remember
like the moment where you were like oh
this is this is a like this this is one
of them ones
yeah well like when I first did it I
just was like on some regular like oh
yeah this [ __ ] slap you tell me yeah
yeah once I put this one Myspace was
cracking so once I put it on my MySpace
and just all the locals start grabbing
it and putting it on their page not to
see other people put it on there and I'm
just like oh okay they [ __ ] with the
song but then I went to jail and when I
got out of jail I went to jail for a
year and when I got out that's when it
was like big as [ __ ] then it was on
YouTube and all that because that like
we didn't really have no nobody was
dropping [ __ ] on YouTube then it was
like all my special so once I got out
that's when I really knew like
oh yeah I had a show the first day I got
out of jail the day I got out I went
before I did my first show ever what
year was this like 2012 2011
2007. oh [ __ ] wait when was when did
Noah come out No Hoe came out only on
MySpace
2007. it didn't hit Youtube and all that
[ __ ] until like late 2008 Jesus so it
was just so you got out of jail and you
had a you had a show already booked I
have a cell book shout out to DJ
Slowpoke he uh put up on me and and he
had a party he was like man they love
your [ __ ] he like you gotta come you
gotta come do the song wow I went and
did the song and and lightweight froze
up then when I seen how the whole crowd
New Year knew the words and [ __ ] that
that's who made that's how I started
started to stomp to know how because
that that was the first thing I seen wow
as soon as the beat came on the whole
party stomping I'm like oh that's crazy